what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers live together under one roof
player stop being polite and start
getting real this is the champion I kick
Sheen's and knees like their boss
uzuki Falls like their boss I am so
pumped to join Chelsea because I was in
danger of actually winning things at
doorman and that would go against
everything the US Men's National Team
believes him every time he gets a bad
result I take a hard look in the mirror
and that blames officials to win the cut
of the grass the smells of a stadium he
I'm back and winning is in my genes
[Music]
nice to finally build up that shadow hey
Christian or not to be that guy but
would you send my Ronaldo Jersey of
course
tiny oh it's from when I was a baby it's
from when you were a baby oh my god
you're like a man now and you are a
legend merci Mon Ami a legend like Raoul
or pelé or Figo legends are old no a
mile
oh thank you for seeing me doctor
Iceland guy I'm having an emergency oh
no did you chip a tooth what no my teeth
are perfect I hear because I think I'm
aging I don't think he understands what
a dentist does Christiano you have the
body of a 23 year old hunty three to see
her go all the doctors say I have bottie
of 22 year olds now he tells me 23 this
is more serious than I thought I thought
it best to seek out advice from another
events legend one who has suffered for
many years with the aging aging-- is
nothing to fear I have been 50 years old
since I was 25 it's just scary to think
that one day I might not be the best
player in the world maybe it's time for
you to take a long look in the beer
oh nice do you have a mirror no what I
mean is do you expect to play this game
forever
nobody can play this game forever you
are mortal you can die you're going to
get old you are going to die so at this
point I'm like for someone known for his
passes and drea can be quite a straight
shooter so so what am I gonna have to
like retire some day not yet you still
up a few years with the old lady
what do you mean old lady Georgina is 25
I mean you Vento's okay but then what
then you do it all the former elite
players - are you an ageing soccer or
sorry football star in Europe come join
MLS where you can score three goals a
game make hundreds of millions of
dollars and you won't get bothered on
the streets because no one will
recognize you know the u.s. dollar may
be worth less than euros and pounds in
MLS you may be forced to play defense
and take commercial flights also
everyone has guns come on over it's
actually more challenging anything
believe me oh hello Ronaldo I'm so
scared
please tell me retirement will be okay
oh no it's great you get to eat whatever
you want
[Music]
[Music]